a homecoming for Demar Hamlin and I can
confirm that he is doing well and this
is the beginning of the next stage of
his recovery following a week of
treatment in Cincinnati the NFL Stars
discharged from the hospital and back in
Buffalo we understand the the
significance of the injury and the
situation tomorrow's coach excited for
his return I just think you know having
him nearby you can feel uh you know his
energy and that just feels like he's
back home and and I think that's that's
that's great news and he still has
obviously some things to go through
with the medical team we're encouraged
by his progress now demar's doctors
reveal what comes next he is going to be
observed and monitored to ensure that
there's no impact on the flight of his
condition or on his lungs normal
recovery from something like this is
going to be measured in weeks to months
and he's been a little bit ahead of that
at each at each stage
and UC Medical Center sharing this pic
on Twitter telling the former patient
quote congratulations Demar you won just
he uh hearing and seeing him open his
eyes amazing it's a really tough moment
so to have so many people unite around
this challenging time for them you know
I think it makes a difference this this
comes after the 24 year old returned to
Instagram over the weekend telling fans
quote the love has been overwhelming but
I'm thankful for every single person
that prayed for me and reached out
I'm cherishing at every moment I can on
Sunday he made a heart symbol with his
hands and rock day love for Demar shirt
as his team played their first game
since Demars collapse Lamar Hamlin has
been down for over nine minutes now
across the sports world it's been a
week-long show of support for the Bill's
safety after suffering cardiac arrest on
the field last Monday
everybody
what we saw was a a player who had a
direct impact to the middle of their
chest and this is what we consider blunt
trauma when someone has a Sudden Impact
to our blood trauma to the chest if it
happens at a specific part of the
cardiac cycle then that can lead to a
ventricular arrhythmia or an unstable
heart arrhythmia which can ultimately
lead to sudden Cardiac Arrest he's up
he's walking around he's got an amazing
genuine sense of humor and his family is
amazing and we're happy he's with them
the NFL's officially canceled the
postponed game with both teams weighing
their options in the aftermath we will
all have grown as people and by going
through an experience like this it's
really incredible to watch how
encompassing it's been around the NFL
around the world really